Speaker 1: Let's see. Let's go next to let's go to
snug Wrangler. And the thing about snug Wrangler
is Snug Wrangler is a professional member, but
nugs phone calls are not at the same caliber as
the Mims, but what's going on snug?
Speaker 2: Oh, David. Oh, mom, no.
Speaker 1: OK.
Speaker 4: So I was reading a piece
over at the American Prospect, a progressive news
magazine, and there was a piece there talking
about profit rates should be included in economic
data, not just wages, unemployment rate, prices,
etc.. What do you think about this and how
do you see things changing if profits were
actually studied and included in economic data?
Speaker 1: Oh, aren't they in a way in so let
me see if I can think that through? So you're
saying, OK, we have a lot of different ways
of measuring how an economy is doing.
We can look at the unemployment rate,
we can look at wages, we can look
at GDP, we can look at inflation,
consumer confidence. You're saying let's include
corporate profits in that list of metrics.
Speaker 4: Yeah, you know, that way we could gauge
maybe if there's a profit gouging stuff like that.
The piece I was reading was also talking
about how it's not really studied. So it's
it's hard to, I guess, use that as a
measurement, even if it should be somehow.
Speaker 1: I am always into having
more information rather than less. I
think you're onto something which is there.
What are we? It's a hard thing to calculate
in the sense that are we talking about the average
profit margin? Are we talking about dollars?
Is it weighted based on company size? I
think if I knew a little more about what
exactly would be measured, I could give you a
more definite opinion about it. But I'm always
for having more information rather than less.
Speaker 4: Yeah, all those things mentioned,
you know, could be possible, definitely is
an area of study that should be looked into.
I agree with you should also be some
kind of measurement of how many,
how many times people are using their toilet.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, if it's if you have a
president, OK, you're playing clips. Yeah. Listen,
if you have a regime where people are flushing 10
to 15 times, that can't possibly be as good as if
people are only flushing once. I agree with you.
OK, thank you. Thank you. All right, Doug
Wrangler with a better phone call than normal,
I like it coming in with the with
the SoundClips. Very, very good.